it is a seriously [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
timeline that we are living in so let's
get to the timeline that we're living in
because that is some of the news today
is hashtag enforce the subpoenas
and rick wilson went on a rant today uh
let's see if we can find the video rant
um now rick wilson in this rant um
is explaining why everyone should be
[ __ ] pissed and we should be [ __ ]
pissed we should be absolutely [ __ ]
pissed about this and we should stay
pissed about this until this comes to a
conclusion
and i i think rick wilson um to some
degree
knows that he's um
incorrect in some of his assumptions
here but we should make these the
assumptions if we as if we only assume
that they're gonna do their job and not
hold them accountable then they may not
do their [ __ ] job
they may not do their [ __ ] job where
is this [ __ ] thing at
i know did he he didn't he didn't delete
this [ __ ] video did he
i tweeted it somewhere
but the point is is that rick wilson
knows
that these people have to be held
accountable to do their [ __ ] here it
is to do their [ __ ] job
and
that is the most important thing here
folks uh i haven't done this in a while
i guess this is whatever periscope is at
the equivalent to now
um
it got cut off at the end of lunch with
lincoln i hadn't planned it uh but i
wanted to say a few things
i am hearing from
multiple
people now that the subpoenas are not
going to be in four
now rick you gotta remember rick plays
politics he's with the lincoln project
he's one of the co-founders of lincoln
project so he's really playing politics
here and that's the whole point that's
what this is is the [ __ ] committee
members are trying to play politics
trump is trying to play politics they're
all trying to play politics with this
serious [ __ ] issue and really the
only way to break break this damn of
this just absolute [ __ ] that trump
has executive power and
bannon writing a letter which we'll
probably get to here in the thread
eventually
is that somehow this is political it's
not po it should not be political it
should not be it should just be an issue
that we take care of
we have seditious
treasonous people in this country that
want to overthrow the constitution of
the united states and they tried to do
it and there is evidence that they tried
to do it
and we should sniff out
every [ __ ] nook and cranny look
underneath every [ __ ] stone
and leave no no stone unturned
to figure out who it was what the [ __ ]
they were doing how they were planning
and how this happened
and we should be pissed the entire
[ __ ] way the entire [ __ ] way we
should be absolutely [ __ ] pissed
because if we're not if we're just like
ah [ __ ] it then it will happen again and
that's what rick's saying
that the commission is basically going
to slow roll the entire thing
and that they're not going to take it
seriously if you don't enforce the
subpoenas
if you don't enforce the subpoenas
hang it up now
just declare trump's president again and
tell steve bannon he can be the emperor
of the [ __ ] right-wing universe and
let it all go if you're not serious
about it if you're gonna play [ __ ]
around with it if you're gonna bring in
a bunch of soft-handed academic you know
[ __ ] about it and talk about the
closest of rhodoclosation get the [ __ ]
out of here these are criminals who try
to overthrow the united states
government they can and that's it that's
it that's why we should be [ __ ]
pissed is these are criminals that tried
to overthrow the constitution of the
united states and we should not let the
[ __ ] up we should not
let up we should continue to pound and
pound and pound and it doesn't matter
who's holding them accountable rather
it's [ __ ] democrats the select
committee liz cheney adam king singer
whoever it is we have to hold them
accountable to get some accountability
from these [ __ ] criminal seditious
treasonous [ __ ]
inspired to try to overthrow the united
states government and for the democrats
on the committee in the leadership side
who are telling people that this is they
want to get this over with
what the hell is wrong with you these
people wanted to kill you
they came to murder you
they would have dragged you out into the
street and stomped you to death
i mean aoc had to put tennis shoes on to
in case she had to run from these people
she had to put her [ __ ] tennis shoes
on in case she had to run
for her life
that's what happened that's what [ __ ]
happened here so we must we must stay
pissed we must stay angry and we must we
must hold the people who are going to
hold these people accountable that is
the only way we get accountability here
we don't get accountability by just
yelling and screaming about how oh well
they were
it was a coup attempt no
if they're not going to do anything
about the coup attempt then we need to
be mad and angry at them
because capitulation to this cheeto dust
kangaroo coup attempt
capitulation to that
is almost as bad if not worse than the
actual attempt of the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
and if you don't punish them and
investigate them and bring them to
justice they'll do it again
a coup attempt that is not punished is a
training exercise
so look this is one of the things i i at
the lincoln project we're really
we're really focused on right now
is the fact that you know our friends of
the democratic party often say oh we've
got this we understand how to do this
it's okay it's fine don't worry you know
you guys don't have to we don't we don't
need the hard edge yard dogs like you
guys all the time well guess what you do
you know why because in virginia we have
to continue to stay pissed and he's
going to talk about the virginia race
here which uh absol absolutely should be
on everyone's radar of what is happening
we have to pile votes on these
[ __ ] in virginia just like we
did in the california recall
the push for the calorie california
recall to make sure that they piled the
votes against that [ __ ] nazi that
goddamn fascist larry elder that
trump-humping piece of [ __ ]
he was he was trumpism for trumpism was
cool the guy was saying trumpy [ __ ] for
for 30 years he's been a [ __ ]
well we need to make sure that terry
mcauliffe wins the race in virginia by
mountains
mountains of [ __ ] votes mountains
you're tied in a race where you should
be stomping the living [ __ ] out of
trump's candidate in virginia you've got
a candidate glenn younkin goes on seb
gorka's neo-nazi white power radio hour
and the democrats are not stomping the
[ __ ] out of him right now every day
every single person talking about it are
you insane
you've got this one six commission where
you are clearly not
playing by the same rules that they're
playing by they're gonna the republicans
gonna delay they're gonna vamp they're
gonna try to make this thing into a a
giant chaos [ __ ] show and we've already
seen that from steve bannon uh steve
bannon's lawyers uh wrote a letter
saying oh well all i'm doing i'm not i'm
not defying the subpoena i'm just
listening to the executive order of the
president of the united states which he
he does not have ex he does not have
executive privilege the only person that
has executive privilege here is whoever
holds the office because it's the actual
office who holds the executive privilege
that's what these [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
don't understand about this country the
constitution or even the democratic
republic that they even [ __ ] live in
is that the guy or the gal or whoever
the [ __ ] it is that holds the office of
president united states is only
president temporarily
they just hold that office they hold
that power temporarily the office is the
thing that has the executive privilege
the executive branch of our government
which is formed by the constitution
holds the executive privilege and
because they don't even know that simple
[ __ ] concept they have no [ __ ]
clue they have no [ __ ] clue that's
why they hate our democracy that's why
they hate our constitution and they want
to tear it to the ground those fascists
sadist treasonous [ __ ]
because it doesn't work for them
because their orange deity isn't the
[ __ ] dictator the cheeto dust mobster
is not in control
he doesn't have executive privilege
anymore he does not hold the office of
the president of the united states he is
a former he's a [ __ ] two-time loser
got it
got it go back to [ __ ] moral [ __ ]
and play golf you fat [ __ ] you do not
have executive privilege and neither do
your nazi [ __ ] storm troopers they
don't have executive privilege here the
only people that have executive
privilege is who the office of the
president united states says has
executive privilege and that's the
process here that's where rick wilson is
kind of getting this wrong is it can't
just
you know like a penalty flag throw up a
criminal referral there's a process for
the criminal referral but what rick
wilson is right about is you should stay
angry and pissed
until that [ __ ] penalty flag is
thrown
you should [ __ ] crowd the [ __ ] the
whole goddamn space
of anger and and vitriol
until we get this accountability taken
because it only takes one it only takes
one [ __ ] just one [ __ ]
to comply with these subpoenas
one [ __ ] to be criminally
charged to defy these subpoenas
and i think the exact person to do that
is mark meadows i think you can pressure
mark meadows
i think that's the guy he's he is going
to bend at a criminal contempt charge in
a federal court no [ __ ] way is he not
going to bend at a criminal contempt
charge in a federal court
mark meadows will fold like a cheap ass
lawn chair
a cheap [ __ ] lawn chair he will
cave
let's listen to what rick's the rest he
has to say to get away from justice
if you subpoena these guys and then you
say we're not going to enforce the
subpoenas and you don't bring down the
full [ __ ] weight and and fury
you're not only doing you're not really
making a tactical political mistake
you're making a fundamental
constitutional mistake by pissing away
power that the constitution gives to
congress
if you will not aggressively investigate
and hold people to account who are who
attempted to overthrow the united states
government in a violent coup
then [ __ ] it go home
[ __ ] it resign today and just burn the
building down on your way out because
that's what's gonna happen i love how
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em that's that
i'm telling you that is the that is the
[ __ ] the the the rally cry [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em i don't care if they think they
have executive privilege who cares if
they're whiny little [ __ ] snowflakes
bitching about how oh we're patriots and
blah blah blah and election fraud and
trump lost and bless you [ __ ] them [ __ ]
em [ __ ]
these people will be back
they will do worse than they did before
they will they will be empowered they
will be they will be enthusiastic and
you know what you're setting the grounds
for all the shenanigans to continue for
the voter fraud it's to continue for all
this [ __ ] in the states for these
guys to turn it into a giant culture war
get your [ __ ] together pull your heads
out of your asses do not treat this like
something it's just a delay so you can
go back to talking about the
infrastructure bill and health care are
you insane
get your [ __ ] together
you must you must you must treat the 1-6
commission as it should be like a law
enforcement and counter-terrorism
operation you must bring these people
into the spotlight you must embrace the
spectacle you must eat up all the time
and scenery and daylight to show who
they are to the american people
all right folks happy friday other than
that
and uh i guess this is what periscope is
now which i haven't done for a very long
time
yeah they [ __ ] changed periscope they
changed it and that's one reason why
i'll tell you that's one reason why
sometimes the viewing windows don't come
up is because they [ __ ] change some
[ __ ] and it's not working properly
twitter get off your asses and fix that
[ __ ] too we need to be pissed about that
not as pissed about you know our
democracy but
you know this functionality of of social
media to get information out there and
and to to make sure everyone knows this
information is critically important
twitter
okay well i'll get off my twitter
soapbox there
oh oh oh oh oh i do want to i wanna i
know i don't wanna i don't want to leave
that alone rick wilson um let's go back
to the the trends here
because what is he trending at he was
he's still at number three casey kasem
number three
in the insurrection institution rick
wilson okay
i always feel like casey kasem you know
all lucky there look who's at the top
because here's here's what happened
so rick not only did the video he did a
um a a a
a thread a diatribe thread
shredding the january 6 commission now
understand that rick here is also he
also tweeted that he hopes he's wrong
but it doesn't matter if he if he's
wrong that's good if rick wilson ends up
being totally wrong about this and the
january 6 committee the 1-6 committee
does their [ __ ] job and rick wilson
is completely [ __ ] wrong that's good
for our democracy
rick wilson we should all hope that rick
wilson is [ __ ] dead wrong here
and we should all be [ __ ] pissed that
they're not doing something until they
do something and prove us wrong that's
what we should be pissed about prove us
wrong
uh liz cheney responds to
rick
pretty quickly now if you guys don't
know who liz cheney is um liz cheney is
the daughter of the uh of darth vader do
you guys remember darth vader from the
movie uh star wars yeah that's um
i guess that would it she's like leia's
uh stepsister who learned the dark side
right if if it were in the star wars
timeline
because she's definitely she definitely
does not use the force for good um but
here
here she is um responding to rick wilson
this is not true
which
uh if you believe liz cheney that's a
good thing if if you believe liz cheney
that this is not that what rick wilson
is not saying or what
rick wilson is saying is is not true
that is a good [ __ ] thing that's a
fantastic thing if you believe her and
she's actually telling the truth
that the 1-6 committee is making
significant progress and we will enforce
subpoenas this this is a member not only
of the one six committee but the
republican
member of the one six committee her and
adam kings and
kensinker are what makes it bipartisan
here
and if liz cheney wins this war with
this one six committee with her party
the trumpian part of her party she will
likely be one of the leaders of the
republican party on the other side of
trumpism
and this is why because she is willing
to say here this is super important we
will enforce subpoenas
not we might not maybe like adam schiff
yesterday said uh it's possible that we
could enforce subpoenas she's saying we
will enforce a penis and then she's also
saying committee statement coming soon
so they've had this prepared rick wilson
knew this that they had this prepared
that there's this process and there's
this time delay between the time that it
expires and the time that something
happens rick wilson is making sure that
the entire country knows to be [ __ ]
pissed if they don't hold these people
accountable and we will hold them
accountable that's important we must
hold the 1-6 committee accountable to
hold others that try to overthrow our
constitution accountable that is what we
have to do
it is a have to it's a must
so that was uh liz cheney's response
to rick's um little thing and mayo here
she's a little worried and everyone
should be concerned about this why is
rick wilson from the lincoln project
trying to [ __ ] up my weekend
i mean everyone should be concerned
about this a bad bad tweets this uh rick
rick wilson stop it they will refer this
to the doj it's a process we are dancing
at the highest level possible and trump
trump is trying to run blockade in my
opinion it will not hold water only
delay the inevitable yeah they told me
nothing will pass either
bad's on top of stuff if you're not
following bad company uh here he's on
top of stuff too but i retweeted rick
wilson's video and i said this is what
this is how pissed everyone should be
now regardless if it's right or wrong
because we hope that rick wilson is
completely dead [ __ ] wrong here and
that the 1-6 committee the january 6th
select committee decides to use criminal
referrals if they have to to enforce
this subpoena and i think where they can
really make a a dent is in mark meadows
because i mean steve bannon doesn't give
a [ __ ] if he's criminally charged he's
been criminally charged before
and what does he give a [ __ ]
what does he care dance covino obviously
does not give a [ __ ] about the rule of
law or he'd at least make himself
available to be served the subpoena
and cash patel we know he's
we know we know that [ __ ] had
seditious intent just from the evidence
that has been uh brought forward by the
dod and committees already
about january 6.
okay let's see
so this is the rick wilson thread let's
see if someone else
gets gets a little
pissed off here
okay angry staffer says see breathe
people
um
uh uh thompson and cheney head of uh one
sixth panel say meadows and cash patel
are
so far engaging bannon isn't that's why
bannon had his attorneys wrote a letter
we will not allow any witness to defy a
lawful subpoena or attempt to run out
the clock
and will swiftly consider advancing a
criminal contempt
and that's where your criminal contempt
is going to be is probably with bannon
let's see what this document says
while mr minnows so far engaging
yeah so so even mr meadows is engaging
but bannon is the one who's gonna he's
gonna try to skip town here and that's
why he wrote the letter saying executive
privilege because he's on the phone with
the cheeto dust mobster and they're
trying to figure out how to not get
steve bannon in this [ __ ] hearing and
and under oath because bannon
100
100 was outside the white house and was
the one of the one of the key
key ingredients to organizing this
[ __ ] [ __ ] show of a cheeto dust
kangaroo 2 attempt 100
that's what's happening that's why the
cheeto dust mobster is completely
terrified that's why steve bannon that's
why dan scavino is completely terrified
because scavino probably knows the
goddamn uh whereabouts of bannon and
trump on that day because he was
standing right there and he knew what
was going on between them
i mean
it is it's probably it's likely not just
a coincidence that these four people are
be being subpoenaed to to be deposed
and hand over information for that
deposition all at the same time that's
probably not a coincidence it's probably
because those four people are connected
in some way in this storyline
this timeline of [ __ ] show that we have
going on
as gabe says the the [ __ ] show timeline
um again at three o'clock central four
o'clock he's